but that's the game that's the game the
media will be trying to trick everyone
distracting with [ __ ] look at this
right now there's a war in Iraq there's
a war and Afghanistan still
there's a genocide in Suzanne
and everybody in the country is looking
for the missing white girl in Aruba
family
he's being real
[Applause]
[Music]
as a matter of fact
you are looking at the first [ __ ] that
America has ever looked on the first
listening
is anybody in here gay
get her let's get it I'm totally joking
it's New York yeah are you gay for real
yeah okay so you know the gay marriage
is illegal right why you think that
that's illegal
yeah
in this and it's all good and well you
see here's the thing no matter what your
morality is it's still a secular society
so even if gay marriages against my own
personal beliefs I can't I can't
necessarily believe a government that
would say we don't want to do that for
moral purposes not why you [ __ ]
bombing Iraq like this don't say the
[ __ ] have games like that I
mean if you came to hit me with all this
dubious hands to morality
they say morality because that's what
their constituents need to hear and
because they think that's what their
constituents want to hear but honestly
Bill Clinton said
90 of the [ __ ] that people talk about
has nothing to do with what the actual
job of the president is about you think
president would be sitting around what
time is it 10 o'clock oh we got that
game meeting hey guys what we gonna do
about that man they don't give a [ __ ]
about who actually is gonna give a [ __ ]
big business and I have a whole beliefs
this month that you just don't want to
know
foreign
[Applause]
all right uh it's a tiered it's a tear
listen marriage laws are [ __ ] up in
America I don't think that the
government should have that much say in
actually how people devise a marriage
because of marriage right devoid of any
kind of religious belief or emotion like
love is a business contract Perry and
simple and tons of people in Washington
or legislative bodies even guys like
Elliot Spencer that have wives with [ __ ]
prostitutes living Loveless marriages
and they have these shits arranged
because they're in such a high social
Stratosphere that they have to keep up
with certain appearance so why are they
imprisoned by their own marriage is this
form of economic slavery and if you look
at the way this [ __ ] happens
corporations were made legal in the
United States by the 14th Amendment
right or 15th Amendment which freed the
slaves and none of those writers people
said we want the same rights as those
[ __ ] as collective individuals
right and if you're a collective
individual and two Collective
individuals want to do business with one
another one's masculine one is feminine
so they Define the marriage institution
between man and woman but what if
corporations is gay
just saying
what if Aunt your mama doesn't want to
be with Uncle Ben
wait a minute
what if Uncle Ben wants to do business
with Mr Clean that's all I'm saying
foreign
being in San Francisco first of all the
city's not even gay anymore
gay people can't afford to live there
they just visit
gay people got their money tied up in
other shenanigans
[Music]
don't you remember San Francisco with
that [ __ ] tiger jumped out of
the cage and bit those people up and San
Francisco is so gay the whole city
blamed the Tiger
now they blame the victims they didn't
say [ __ ] about the tiger they said these
people were teasing that tiger that's
irrelevant
Tigers should not be able to jump out of
the cage and kill people at the zoo they
said that that tiger chased one of his
victims 400 yards listen you know how
[ __ ] fast you have to run
outrun a tiger for 400 yards
probably woke up in the hospital with
the NFL recruiter standing over his bed
you did a good son
you did very good
I know this isn't a good time but I'm
with the Cincinnati Bengals
complete coincidence
I think we can tie something and do
something really big with you
one of the guys tagged a bit was Mexican
and the other two were Arabs I said what
who trained this tiger homelands to
carry like everybody
have you ever worked all your life for
something and have it not work out
that happened to me
it was tough think about it
I was gone for 12 years
it's not a little bit of time
it was hell
I watched other [ __ ] that I knew
become very famous
I watched the world go on without me
I mourned the laws of it and after a
while
I didn't care
coming back was terrifying
I understand what I am I really do more
than anybody like when they write about
me in history I'll I'll be dead reading
it like yeah I know they'd say that
I swear to God this might be the noblest
of professions Robin Williams had a bar
that I loved he said comedy is the only
job he can have where you can use
everything you know
and that's true you can use more than
you know if you use what you think use
it
don't be afraid don't let these [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] button your lip
say it anyway
[Applause]
you have no idea what I put this woman
through
if you were just given birth to me that
would have been more than enough but the
fact that she raised me and raised me
well he had a real oral tradition in our
house I knew the word Grio when I was a
little boy agrio was a person in Africa
who's charged with keeping the stories
of The Village everyone would tell gril
the stories and they would remember them
all so that they could tell future
Generations when they got old they'd
tell them to someone else and they say
in Africa when agrio dies it's like a
library was burnt down
and my mother used to tell me before I
ever thought about doing comments she
said you should be a Grio
and she filled me with every story of
black life you know she's educated in
African-American studies and she would
let me understand the context that I was
being raised in that I'm being raised in
a hostile environment that I have to
tame by the time I was 14 years old I
was in nightclubs mastering an adult
world it was terrifying crack epidemic
was going on and my mother would hear
gunshots outside and be scared of death
maybe it's my son but early in my career
if you remember Mom you used to sit in
the club with me she'd do a full day of
work you'd be back there falling asleep
just waiting for me to go on she would
watch my show every night do you know
how long that car ride is home
how many of you have ever heard your
mother say [ __ ] jokes for a little too
much tonight son
I was a soft kid
I was sensitive I cried easy and I would
be scared to fist fight and my mother
used to tell me this thing I don't even
know if you remember but you said this
to me more than once you said Son
sometimes you have to be a lion so you
can be the lamb you really are
remember that for the first time in the
history of America the life expectancy
of white people is dropping because of
heroin because of suicide all these
white people out there that feel that
anguish that mad because they think
nobody cares maybe they don't let me
tell you something I know how it feels
if you're a police officer and every
time you put your uniform on you feel
like you got a Target on your back
you're powered by the ingratitude that
people have when you would risk your
life to save them oh man believe me
believe me I know how that feels
everyone knows how that feels but here's
the difference between me and you you
guys hate each other for that and I
don't hate anybody I just hate that
feeling that's what I fight through
that's what I suggest you fight through
you gotta find a way to live your life
you got to find a way to find joy in
your existence in spite of that feeling
and if you can't do that come get these
[ __ ] lessons thank you very much